here's the legend and I come out and my
big ad lib thing is just a second you're
gonna call me a legend Saturday Night
Live has lost its signature voice as TV
legend Don Pardo has passed away hi I'm
Sophie Chalet c4 et now Pardo died
Monday evening in his sleep at 96 years
old an NBC spokesperson confirmed he had
served nearly 40 years as the iconic
announcer of the late-night comedy show
pictured here in 2010 Pardo became the
first announcer to be inducted into the
television Academy Hall of Fame outside
of SNL Pardo had a lifetime of
experience working on soap operas used
programs and game shows like The Price
is Right and jeopardy but Don - Don are
you there I'm everywhere Joe according
to The Hollywood Reporter Pardo wanted
to retire back in 2004 but was told that
if he chose to accept it he had a
lifetime contract with the network the
only other person to receive that honor
Bob Hope be sure to tune in to
Entertainment Tonight for more on Don
Pardo for ET now I'm Sophia Lacey